[Applause]
i'm about to make a cornstarch fireball
check it out
[Music]
that is awesome but it's not just about
making a giant fireball this is about
real science
what's gonna happen when i put this
butane torch on this teaspoon of corn
flour remember that fireball that you
saw was only two teaspoons of corn flour
but very little happens i mean obviously
the corn flour is burning it's flammable
but
it's not a violent explosion there's no
fireball happening here
why is that well it's because this corn
flower is all in a big lump so there's
not a large surface area where the corn
flour can interact with the oxygen but
if you blow the corn flour out of this
spout then you separate all those little
corn flour particles and there's lots of
area where the oxygen can interact and
burn the corn flour that's why we get
such an amazing huge fireball now we've
changed the funnel you know because it's
only science if you vary something so
we've gone to a longer thinner funnel
let's see if that makes a difference
ready three two one
[Music]
it was different because there were like
there's a lot more flower that came out
but yeah like really
that didn't go and fuego okay we've now
reduced the length of this plastic
tubing which gets me uncomfortably close
to the fireball but i think i should
still be safe
all right let's see if that improves our
fireball
let's go
[Music]
now the cornstarch worked really well i
also tried plain white flour and that
did not go so well attempt number one
making a flower fireball
three
so disappointing what happened to the
flower fireball my suspicion is that the
particles of this flower are not as
small
as the particles in the corn starch but
it could also be that there are
different sugars in here if you've got
an idea about why this plain white flour
didn't work why don't you leave it in
the comments below just be careful don't
do anything stupid with a butane torch
and a bunch of very flammable material
so it's probably a good idea to do this
outdoors and away from anything that it
could possibly catch on fire
[Music]
because the flame has those ions in it
it means that we can break down a
greater distance of hair